[Music]
Disney has created robot acrobats that
perform high-flying stunts
sticking a perfect landing every single
time these stunts Ronix are autonomous
self-correcting and remarkably
human-like so how does the technology
work could it actually change the way
Hollywood makes its blockbuster films
and what do real stunt performers think
about how this could affect their
profession
[Music]
[Applause]
the stunt Tronics project began with a
simple z shaped robot called stickman
unveiled by disney's research team in
May 2018 stickman consists of three
links connected by hinges its legs can
fold into a tuck to z configuration or
unfold into a linear shape stretching
seven feet long about the height of a
human stunt performer who has his arms
raised this tucking and untucking action
allows stickman to adjust its speed of
flight and perform aerial stunts such as
a single backflip and a double backflip
stickman is launched from an elevated
height like this sealing a quick release
clamp detaches the robot from the
ceiling and it flies through the air
along a pendulum to determine what its
body is doing in space the robot
processes data in real time from a
number of onboard sensors a simpler
version of the system used in
self-driving cars it's equipped with
three laser rangefinders which encounter
the ground at different times these
laser rangefinders measure stickman x'
height in midair while a unit of
accelerometers and gyroscopes measure
orientation stickman uses this
information to determine when it should
talk and untuk allowing it to make a
graceful landing every time from this
stick-figure prototype disney created
the more humanoid stunt Ronix which can
control their own posture rotation and
center of mass and can even strike
dramatic superhero poses in midair the
Sun Tronics were developed for Disney's
themed attractions many of which already
future human stunt performers as live
entertainment beyond their use in theme
parks people are speculating that
sentronics will soon play behind the
scenes roles in movies especially action
and superhero movies that involve
extreme stunt work the robots could be
used to test out stunts for at least on
performers like Bobby Holland Hampton
Bobby is one of Hollywood's go-to
stuntmen performing as a stunt double
for actors like Chris Hemsworth Ryan
Reynolds Christian Bale
Jake Gyllenhaal and Chris Evans
while we're rehearsing our stunts for a
movie we build up each stunt in
increments and we start slow and build
it up until the final product and it can
take time but the reason we do that and
take the time is because it's the
saint's way to do it so we could
potentially introduce a stunt robot to
test the stunt for us to a point where
we think okay well let's not keep
beating up the human to get it right
let's maybe use the stunt robot for a
section of it and then when we feel it's
ready to plug the human in we plug the
human in or I mean it would actually
make me a lot happier if I could get
stunt robot to test up into a certain
point of a stunt and then I'll just take
the robot out I'll step in and do it
maybe a couple of times and we're good
to go so I mean it sounds good to me
some people have voiced concern that the
rapid advancement of robotics could
threaten the jobs of actors and stop
performers alike listen when you've got
an actor like Chris Hemsworth I don't
need any robot out there in the world
that can be as good-looking as him I
think the actors are pretty safe I
certainly don't think that it's going to
be a problem for some performers I think
you always need the human element of
anything and even when you know you work
alongside the special effects teams they
always need a human element even if
they're going to CGI that later there's
a place for everything I think it could
help both sides special effects and not
you know it sounds like an amazing bit
of technology that could come into the
film industry and and enhance it
I don't think it's gonna change it but I
think you could enhance it
[Music]